♪ ♪ ♪
les paysans ne doutent pas
des changements climatiques :
des lacs ont disparu,
des terres, fertiles il y a
envahies par les dunes,
le cycle des sécheress
des inondations s'accélère.
ADAM ISSOUFOU, agronome, Inst.
recherche agronomique du Nssssss
d'inondations qui se faisaient
dans le temps peut-être tous
les 10 ans ou tous les 20 ans;
là, on les a pra................
- En 2010, nous étions au Niger
pour couvrir une grande
sécheresse qui avait été suivie
par des s s s s s s s s s s s st
d'enfants en état critique
de malnutrition.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Donc l'enfant, il est là,
il est dans une altération de
la conscience depuis deux jours,
avpeut pas respirer de lui-même.
Là, c'est un état critique.
- La petite Baratou ne pesait
que 5,4 kilogrammes, le poids
mais elle avait deux ans.
suivant notre tournage, après
frfrfrfrfrfrances inimaginables.
Dr AMADOU SIDIBÉ, dir. soins
intensifs, Hôpital de Madarounf
dans le monde, c'est vraiquququ,
mais il y en a dans les foyers
ici où il n'y en a
Donc ça nous choque vraiment,
cette inégalité de
la répartition de la nourriture.
- Depuis cette famine, des d d s
comme Baratou continuent
de mourir de faim chaque ann
Après une autre mauvai
récolte, Tahirou Niandou,
qui a huit enfants, se résigne
pour sauver ses plus jeunes
de la famine.
Sonyzyzyzyzyzyzyzyzé,
est pourtant dans une région
qui avait la réputation,
d'être le grenier du Niger.écéct
la déforestation ont provoqué
l'ensablement des terres.
♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪ ♪
Au 20e siècle, les grandes
sécheresses dans le Sahel
aux 20 ans.
Dans les années 2000,
c'était aux cinq ans.
Maintenant, les récoltes brûlent
BARKIRÉ GABDAKOYE,
ingénieur ag
- Les sécheresses sont beaucoup
plus fréquentes, c'est une fois
- Cet agronome, formé
à l'Université de Menenenenenent
des terres fertiles au Niger.
Les nombreuses sécheresses
ont éliminé le couvert végétal,
il n'y a s s s s s s s s s s s e
l'érosion.et des inondations fae
que des terres importantes
lessivées ou simplement envahies
par le sable soit venant
de plus loin, du désert.
- La désertification galopante
atteint maintenant le fleuve
Cours d'eau mythique qui abrite
encore des hippopotame
le fleuve permettait
aux agriculteurs de produire,
entre les récoltes de céréales,
des légumes.
Ce
ADAM ISSOUFOU, agronome, Inst.
- Ce fleuve est totalement
ensablé,
un phénomène d'ensablement
de ce fleuve.
des inondations beaucoup plus
a a a a a a a a a a a alimentae
est permanente.
Quand les productions sèch
puis les enfants meurent
"Peu importe la nature
de l'aide, dit-il, elle est
est mauvaise."
Yi i i i i i i i i i i i à
quitter son village et son pays
pour aller au Burkina Faso
♪ ♪ ♪
Les plus vieux sont aussiésésés
cette région du nord du Mali,
autrefois trègrgrgrgrgrgrgrgrgrd
lac Faguibine a complètement
disparu; la végétation
et les arbres ont suivi.
Le boiisisisisisisisisisisisisi.
ueueueueueueueueueueueueueue de
nombreux conflits entre paysans
et éleveurs, qui doivent aller
leurs troupeaux pour trouver l .
"Entre éleveurs et
cultivateurs, dit-il, il n'y aee
est restreint, tout le m
le veut."
- Cette dune de sable
n'était pas là.
- Les jeunes famillesde la régi.
HAMA ABACRENE,
maire de Bintagoungou, Mali
- Donc c'est une école d'à peu
cela veut dire toute
une généra
perdue, une génération
préparée pour l'exode
- C'est le choix impossible de
: : : : : : : : : : : : : : :
rester dans un village sans
avenir et risquer de se faire
recruter par u
ou prendre la route de l'exil,
traverser le désert et
la Méditerranée, au risque
ililililililililililililililili.
♪ ♪